it really is true that I didn't believe
in weekends I didn't believe in
vacations the biggest transformation for
me was living my life with intention
we were illegal immigrants well gray
area wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some of the
best lessons from billionaire
entrepreneurs enjoy okay let's kick it
off with lesson number one make
sacrifices with Bill Gates I think you
know you can over a worship and
mythologize the idea of working
extremely hard for my particular makeup
I mean it really is true that I didn't
believe in weekends I didn't believe in
vacations I mean you know I knew
everybody's license plate so I could
tell you over the last month when their
car had come and gone from the parking
lot so I don't recommend it a I don't
think most people would enjoy it once I
got into my 30s I could hardly even
imagine how I had done that because by
then some natural behavior kicked in and
I loved weekends and you know my
girlfriend liked vacations and that
turned out to be kind of a neat thing
now I took lots of vacations my 20 year
old self is so disgusted with my current
self you know I I was sure I would never
do anything but riding coach you know
now I have a plane so it's very much
counter revelations have taken place at
high speed but yes it is nice if during
those first several years if you have a
team that's chosen to be pretty maniacal
about the company and how far that goes
you know should have a mutual
understanding so you're not one person
expecting one thing another person's
expecting another thing and you'll have
individuals who who have you know health
or relatives or things that are
distracted but yes I have a fairly
hardcore view that there should be a
very large
a sacrifice made during those those
early years lesson number two
live your life with intention with Oprah
Winfrey 2020 you want it to be the year
of transformation yeah an abundance of
life experiences Oprah so what would you
say has been your biggest personal
transformation yet the biggest
transformation for me was living my life
with intention you know what I know I
live by this law that's the third law of
motion physics what you put out its
coming back but before you even put it
out you have an intention and so to have
a clarity of intention about what you
actually want to do and why you want to
do it is the most important thing and
then to just set that vision and have
every step you make move you in the
direction of that vision and doesn't
mean that every day it's gonna happen
some days you're off track like I
intended to work out 45 minutes I only
got in 37 this morning that's better
than zero and that's that's that so I
said okay at least you got some movement
in and I'll go back and I'll make up the
other eight later but you just made it
actually as I was walking I think I
think this is gonna be so it's it's
about its daily renewal it's not one big
gigantic goal it's every day coming back
giving yourself the opportunity to get
it right because that's what every
sunrise means it's oh gosh it's another
chance to get it right lesson number
three persevere with Elon Musk when did
it occur to you that zip 2 might be a
success well I mean when we first
started out I think our ambitions were
really quite quite low it was really to
make enough money to pay the rent yeah
we got a visa that's money that was yeah
I thought we thought it was all over
then yeah it was pretty crazy I mean
when we start out at 95 we're literally
at the beginning we had one computer
which would be the web server during the
day and and
at night I'd program on it and and we'd
sleep in the office yeah we couldn't
afford to - yeah Department it was
cheaper to rent the office than to rent
an apartment so we just rented the
office and stepped in the office and
showered at the YMCA and me the worst
part was eating a jack-in-the-box three
times yeah yeah man this I'll see it's
really difficult to get food at Palo
Alto after like 10:00 p.m.
it's like jack-in-the-box and a few
other options we rotate it through the
jack-in-the-box menu through the end of
95 word that's essentially were just
sleeping in the office and chairing the
YMCA and then and around the end of 95
as where net skate went public and and
then whether or not somebody knew what
the internet was they knew that you
could make money on the internet somehow
or even if it's only on the greater fool
theory so when we went and talked to
venture capitalists in early 96 there
was a much greater interest in what we
were doing in fact the round closed and
like maybe a week or something it's
crazy yeah we went from sleeping in the
office to people throwing me at the game
this is a financial crowd so you guys
see these numbers every day but for us
to hear we'll give you three million
dollars yeah Oh extremely we thought
they were crazy why would they do that
mmm it was literally these people are
insane they obviously do not realize
we're sleeping in the office in fact
when they when they did fund us they
realized that we were illegal immigrants
well it's a gray area
yeah illegal immigrants we were sleeping
in the office we didn't have a car we
had one car with the wheel kept falling
off but actually yeah the wheel that
actually fall off the car yes and then
an adventure kept us actually bought us
cars yeah well like I gave a sporty
grand there's 40 grand to go buy cars
which at the time was more money than I
ever seen also if you want to have more
confidence in self-love check out my 254
series they're free the links are joined
on the description below you really have
to believe the Internet's going to be
mainstream a lot of people are gonna get
out there and use it become so skilled
so vigilant so flat
out fantastic at what you do that your
talent cannot be dismissed it's so
difficult to be a small business owner
in China
it took me five mouths to one five
hundred dollars lesson number four think
long term with Warren Buffett if you buy
a business did you buy a farm you know
you go up and look you know every couple
weeks to see how far the corn is up and
you know you worry too much about
whether somebody says this is gonna be a
year of low prices because it's exports
are being affected or anything like that
you know you buy a farm and you hold it
for got one farm that I bought in the
1980s and my son runs it but I've been
there once you know I mean it it doesn't
grow faster if I go and stare at it you
know I can't cheer for it you know more
effort more effort or something like
that and I know there's going to be some
years when prices are gonna be good and
some when the prices aren't gonna be
good I know those years when yields will
be better than others but about the form
and if it just and I don't care about
economic predictions on or anything of
the sort I do care that'll worry over
the years it's well tended to in terms
of rotating crops and I hope yields get
better which they generally have in fact
that farm a hundred years ago what about
wood produced 30 bushels maybe 35
bushels of corn per acre now on a good
year you know it'd be 200 I mean we've
really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices go
back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little is because we've just
gotten better and better whether it's
cotton or whether it's corn or soy beans
are all kinds of things and you and I
have benefited from that apples well
it's a it's a long term investment and
if you owned if you own the best auto
dealership in town the best brand and
added something good running it wouldn't
drop by every day and say you know how
many people have come in today or you
know I think interest rates are going up
a little maybe I'll slow down our sales
or they know you buy it knowing there's
365 days
and you're gonna own it for 20 years so
that's 70 300 days and you know they're
gonna things are gonna be different from
day to day and your dear you shouldn't
buy it up the day to day stuff is
important lesson number five be
different with Jeff Bezos we're very
interested in physical stores and we
have it I've been asked for years we
ever open physical stores literally 20
years of an asset question and I always
say yes but only when we have a
differentiated differentiated offering
something's not me too because that
space physical stores is so well served
if we offer a me-too product offering
it's not gonna work we're and it's also
just we're not very good at that most of
the whenever we've tried dabbling in
something that's a meet to service we
tend to get beaten it doesn't work we're
our culture is much better at pioneering
and inventing and so we have to have
something that's different and that's
what Amazon Go is it's completely
different the Amazon bookstore
completely different and we have ideas
about how to merge Prime and Whole Foods
to make that those are still rolling out
you haven't seen them yet but to make to
use Amazon Prime to make Whole Foods a
very differentiated experience and so
what we're gonna be able to do is take
some of our resources some of our
technical technological know-how and and
expand the Whole Foods mission they have
a great mission which is to bring
nourishing food to everybody organic
nourishing food to everybody and but you
know we have a lot to bring to that
table in terms of resources but also in
terms of operational excellence and in
terms of technology know-how lesson
number six think about the future with
Jack Ma is there such a great
infrastructure of the internet you have
with the so many people in the world
today know by the internet there today
will be more than 1.7 billion people are
already online but that time total China
less than like 500 people using Internet
it's difficult but as I said just in the
other room everybody when you have a
dream you have to dream globally but you
have to win locally
you have to survive today but you also
have to think about the future if you do
not think about the future if you do not
have a vision for 10 years later what
will you be you will never have a great
people follow you and join your company
but if you cannot survive you go nowhere
unless the number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip is do
what you love with Mark Zuckerberg
here's the thing it wasn't so long ago
that you know I was a student and you
know sitting in in a seat in an
auditorium like you guys are here today
listening to I remember very
specifically this time when Bill Gates
came to talk it at Harvard and I'm like
wow how do you how do you do that and
but you know the trick is is that the
media likes to sensationalize this as if
you have some Eureka moment or you are
some singular person who can't build
something on your own and that's just
not how the world works
you know when I was in school I built a
lot of stuff that I just liked building
there was not a single moment when I
when I had some revelation that Facebook
was gonna be awesome that's not maybe
how the media or movies or whatever
would like to portray things it's not
it's much less exciting but the reality
is I think most I services in the world
that reach the scale that Facebook has
you start off building something that
you care about and you know you don't
necessarily think it's gonna be that big
I didn't you know I built Facebook the
first version of Facebook for my college
community because I wanted to be able to
connect to the people at my school and I
remember very clearly talking to my
friends at the time and saying you know
it's how cool is it that we have built
this community for our school you know
one day it's gonna be awesome when
somebody else builds this for the world
because something like this needs to
exist for the world but it didn't even
occur to me that you know
friends and I might be able to play a
role in doing that because we were
college students right I mean we didn't
have any you know engineers to work with
or servers or resources or anything like
that and you know there were these huge
companies that deliver products for
hundreds of millions of people right
there's I always assumed that it was
gonna be like Microsoft or Google or
someone would build this for the world
and what basically just happened is it
each step along the way we just kind of
kept doing the next thing and growing
from there and you know there were teams
inside these other companies that that
thought social media was important and
we're working on it
but there were all these different memes
and narratives in the world you know
people would say oh well you know this
is just a fad people are gonna use it
but then they're gonna stop so you know
so a lot of the teams who were working
on didn't take it that seriously or you
know the higher ups and those companies
didn't care send get resources and we
just kept going and going and then
people would say alright well alright
fine so maybe people are using it but
it's never gonna make any money alright
I mean social media doesn't make any
money we just kind of kept going and
going and then pretty soon we had a
service that was bigger than any of
these other ones and that kind of is how
we are here where we are now got a
special bonus lesson from Mark Cuban on
how to play it smart that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video
through taking action here we go number
one how can you better live your life
with intention number two how is your
business going to be different and
number three what do you love to do that
you need to do more of when instead of
just holding on to all of the stock that
you got from Yahoo you did what we call
a collar you collar heads yeah so you
hedged it so tell everybody what went
through your mind because that was a big
bet with huge dollars right and it was a
pretty it was actually pretty simple so
you know hedgy stock if you know Yahoo
paid us in Yahoo stock and you know I
was smart enough to recognize I guess
that what goes up could go down but it
wasn't that big a step because
worth more than a billion dollars how
much did I need right so I was telling
everybody just find me a way to hedge it
so in the event look if the stock price
goes up and I leave something on the
table so be it right but I like that be
next to my name and I wanted to keep it
and so I sold calls bought puts and
effectively hedged it so that by the
time so there was a period of time from
when I'd done that and the internet
stock market kept on going up and and I
told people I had hedged it and Goldman
Sachs the company had told people what
I'd done and I remember going on CNBC
the business Channel and then the guy
going don't you feel stupid that Yahoo
stock is kept on going up and you had
this edge and I'm like yeah I feel so
stupid riding around my g5 that I bought
online you know and and it was just like
not to sound like a crazy greedy greedy
capitalist but yeah and it was like I
just don't want to screw it up and so I
hedged it and then the internet bubble
burst and I was fully protected and
actually even made a little bit more
money and you know middle um you know
the motto that the what I learned was
you just don't need to be greedy you
know I was very very blessed I was very
fortunate look I didn't plan the
internet stock market to go up and I
didn't plan it to go down so I was lucky
in terms of scale and I didn't want to
screw it up
and so I hedged
if you want a few more lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you know I worked
weekends I didn't believe in vacation
and so I I really pushed people to work
hard have you ever met a person who was
a great reader when they were young who
was not successful